my name is Emily doddle I'm a senior
inventive scientist in the data science
and AI research org at AT&T Labs and
I've been there now about four years I'm
so I'll be speaking with you today about
what I called iterative research and
practice and essentially what I mean by
this is I often think about the problems
that I work on and three distinct but
certainly not independent ways and
revisiting it from these from these
angles so the first is the question you
want to answer how do you define it the
second is how do you want to solve that
problem how do you want to approach that
that question
and the third is how do you actually
code and deploy a solution to that
problem so in thinking about sort of how
you go back and forth between those it
is always the case almost always the
case that the limitations in place from
one of those those phases can inform
your choices for another and so I'm
gonna be talking today about a project
I've been working on to AT&T for almost
a year now I've been working on DirecTV
advertising for a little over two and in
this particular one we we often found
that there would be a method that did
not have a scalable implementation or
there would be a method that worked but
it didn't quite capture the nuance that
we wanted in which case you then sort of
tweak the method and both of those
become really interesting research
problems and then of themselves so I'll
start with a problem statement here so
as I mentioned I'll be talking about
advertising for some context AT&T serves
over 20 million households with
advertising across its it's cable
platforms so we have DirecTV satellite
which is sort of your standard you have
a set-top box you turn on the TV DirecTV
now is the streaming service and the new
verse is sort of a cable equivalent in
certain parts of the country so for
DirecTV satellite a certain fraction of
those households that have that service
have return path say a set-top box
capabilities meaning their set-top boxes
return data to us so we can learn
information about preferred programs and
viewing habits things like that and so
in this case what we want to be doing is
for a satellite TV which I'll be talking
about today the goal is it's always sort
of there are two flavors here we have
addressable advertising which is
targeted meaning that if you want
I turn on or TV at the same time and we
both are addressable capable an ad spot
might come up and I see one and you see
something completely different
the alternative is linear TV advertising
is sort of the standard this is kind of
the the way it always was which is where
an advertiser buys a specific time on a
specific show and you capture whoever
happens to be tuning in it was often
based on sort of inferred gender and age
demographics which are becoming somewhat
obsolete as targeted advertising is all
around us but it still represents a
really big piece of advertising budgets
so anything we can do even a little bit
to improve reach and accuracy has a
pretty big value add so what we're doing
here is we have these TV program
engagement features we have this return
set-top box data we can gather these
engagement features that tell us how and
when people are watching and how engaged
they are with programs and we use that
then to predict an advertisers audience
what we know to be their relevant
audience or expect to be that can come
to us in one of a few different ways I
won't focus on that too much but the
goal then is once we're able to predict
their relevant audience we can sort of
infer what we know about their viewing
to recommend specific shows or programs
for linear ad buys so that's sort of the
goal here so as a framework for what
those engagement features are our
advertising colleagues in Zander which
is a TN t--'s ad group had come to us
with some features for rune and
attribution literature and so the
original ones were frequency which is
how many unique airings of a program a
household watches the event recency
which means how many days that's their
last viewing event for a program
duration how much time they watch and
consumption method is how they watch it
essentially and so these are a really
good starting point but as you may
imagine the nature of television
programming is that there are different
shows of different lengths you can have
a 30 minute show versus a movie maybe
two hours they can air at different
frequencies so every day versus maybe
once every other week if it's a special
that kind of thinks we had to normalize
these to account for those discrepancies
essentially we also had some information
about how engaged people are by how they
tune away at commercials that actually
there's been some work within research
to show that if you
the more you flip around the more
engaged you are the show if you
continually come back to it which which
makes sense there's a little bit
unexpected so to give you a sense of why
this problem was challenging from a
computational aspect I'll sort of move
through these three phases here to give
you a sense of scale three months of
primetime viewership data yields about
seventy five thousand programs for more
than ten million households is what we
were looking at and so the data sort of
comes to us in this long format here I
sort of have a blue and a brown house
and they represent two individual
households and then for every program
that household watches we have these
different engagement features so often
big data problems are because you have
log data that can be millions billions
trillions of observations in this case
that was certainly a difficulty of the
starting point but we want to do the
modeling for this work the additional
challenge that was somewhat new to us
was how wide it was once we cast it for
modeling so what happens here you're
just sort of turning each household now
has its own bro in our do data set and
we now have for every one of those
programs all the engagement features and
if the household did not watch a program
ever they were filled in with zero which
made numerical sense in this context so
I'll be referring in a bit to what's
called a group and what I mean by that
is you can see that program a has X
number of features associated with it
and program B has X number of features
those features when you look at sort of
a data frame or a data table you don't
necessarily get the fact that those
columns those columns those X columns
are related to each other right that's
somewhat lost but the idea that we want
to take into account is that they are
actually a group of features for a
program so some modeling considers
considerations that we did we first
thought about can we cluster the data to
identify popular programs and that
seemed at first like a viable solution
but we quickly realized that we'd just
be picking up popular programs which was
an idea we wanted to identify programs
that were differentiating our relevant
audience from the rest of the DTV
universe so we knew we wanted to do
classification at that point
additionally there's kind of this
optimization aspect as I mentioned we
want to optimize reach among the
relevant
audience minimize to some extent the
overlap between the programs are
recommending we don't want the same
people seeing a billion ads for this
that sort of thing as well as the cost
of the final recommendation so obviously
buying an ad spot cost money depending
on the program and its popularity those
sorts of things
so typically modeling approaches for Big
Data takes on one of three options
somewhat so you can take a sample and a
statisticians that's always kind of our
first our first move you can move into a
parallel implementation which at AT&T
Labs is is very common or in this case
so we ended up doing a split and conquer
and I'll talk a little bit about why so
what that meant is we split up our
training data into chunks trained to
model in each chunk and then assemble
them together for a final prediction so
moving into approach in methodology I'll
talk about two models that we ultimately
ended up comparing federer of interest
to us so the first here is group
regularized regression also known as
group lasso and to give you a little bit
of intuition here so the loss function
for group lasso is just sort of your
familiar residual sum of squares with a
shrinkage penalty just like a typical
lasso but the shrinkage penalty here is
kind of neat because it applies to the
entire group that entire programs
features meaning that a program's
features will either be all included in
the model or all dropped from the model
so it also gives us some variable
selection by program which is pretty
cool not everything was going to do that
its parametric so there's quite a bit of
tuning involved but as I mentioned it
captured that group structure one of the
problems as I mentioned there was no
scalable implementation here and so my
colleague ritwik Mitra who has been my
partner in all this actually coded up
the entire thing in scratch in our which
is our workhorse language for sure so
that was sort of it's a project all on
its own interpretation we come up with
essentially a program importance so this
is helpful from the coefficients in this
case but that's how we get to the final
program list recommendation from the
initial prediction at a household is
relevant non relevant and it's
interprete below because you have
coefficients this
gaile in the direction is intuitive and
and interpretable performance was not
great and you'll see that in a moment it
just it didn't do quite what we wanted
although we really liked the intuition
behind it so we also looked at XG boost
which i think has been a contributor to
most of the winners of cavalcade all
competitions it's known for model
performance and speed and in our case it
handles sparsity very well so as i
mentioned that why the matrix you can
imagine that now on every household
watches every of each of the 75,000
programs so it did that well there was a
stable out of the box of limitation
there's a package in R that was great
interpretation so you have from tree
based methods very often kind of a
variable important score but again this
was not at the program level it was at
the program feature level so we did have
to roll that up to a program level and
there's no directionality to it so it's
not quite as intuitive but still helpful
information on the last and it did much
better so where have we been using this
I'll go first through performance
measures that you can see sort of power
two final ones performed here so miss
classification error exactly what it
sounds like on our test data we looked
at sensitivity and specificity and one
of the key challenges here is that high
specificity was easier to achieve at the
cost of sensitivity because of the fact
that the data the distribution of
household is very zero inflated meaning
if you think about all of the probes in
our universe here it may be the case at
a very small portion are within the
advertisers relevant audience so sort of
a an intuitive understanding of this say
that you have a hundred households two
of which are in the relevant audience if
you do a naive approach and you label
them all none relevant your true
negative rates gonna be a hundred
percent because you've got all 98 of
those right but your true negative rates
true positive rate is going to be zero
we also looked at top twenty percent
lift which is a pretty common business
metric all this does is we take our
predictions on the test data and we
order the probabilities of descending
order we cut off look at the top twenty
percent what percent of true positive is
do we capture there
so if we capture 80% of true positives
in the top 20% of predictions
that's a lift of four 80/20 and that's
really good so use cases we've done this
you would imagine that viewing habits on
television translates pretty nicely to
other TV shows that you watch and movies
that you may want to see in theaters so
those have been our two use cases so
we've been looking at what are called
tuning campaigns which is when you see
an ad that's like tune in to the show
next week at 9 and also theatrical
release so when a movie is coming out in
theaters so we had done for proofs of
concept and one of them was for a
superhero movie that came out and you'll
see here the results from group regular
lives regression extra boost in both
cases you see in the results in the top
10 programs some superhero movies so
that's kind of that's nice that's
intuitive --xg booths you see a few more
than the group lasso and I'll just
mention this on that index there it's
great if you can say reach 70 percent of
the target with a program but if you're
also reaching 70 percent of the DirecTV
universe of that program you haven't
actually done an enrichment of the
relevant audience there so it's not
super so what you really want to see is
a program that reaches 80 percent of the
relevant audience for example and maybe
20% of all D TV households so it's that
proportion there just that that easy
division that's giving us the index so
anywhere you see that being over one
that represents an enrichment of the
relevant audience from that program so
I'll just point out quickly you see some
programs in the group lasso where
they're sporting events and the index is
only slightly above one what tended to
happen quite a bit was that it picked
out really popular programs so sporting
events things that a lot of people were
tuning into whereas XG booths did a
really good job at finding programs that
had really good reach as well as a
pretty high index and we had some other
metrics that we tagged on for business
purposes to explain these results in an
intuitive manner performance metrics
here I'll just show you I'll point out
the lift for XG boost was 4.5 so it was
pretty good and miss classification
error was only three percent versus
twenty percent for group lasso
so I mentioned the computational piece
that this was sort of this quote-unquote
big data problem and this is the stuff
that I find really fun so how do you
code this up can we break some stuff and
then try again essentially and that's
what we did
so the typical our workflow we realized
very quickly would not scale we sort of
knew that going in so whether if you did
a tidy verse or in my case some big data
table user for your data processing and
then you know shiny ggplot2 Trello scope
all really nice for visualization and
then your modeling you have some really
good we we knew we wanted a tree base
method to start so that's why those were
there
we know that didn't work and so at that
point you sort of have to think about
well how do you choose a tool of all of
the ones you know are available to you
and so here are some of the things that
Rick and I thought quite a bit about so
what does our team already use and and
who do we have working with what tool
and and on what sorts of things we
really wanted to learn something new so
we had a reason to do it and then it's
really about how much time you have to
do it
existing data architecture and back-end
support is huge obviously you can only
use what's available to you and data
handling computational performance also
came into play quite a bit here the big
thing though as I mentioned doing
something seeing if it worked and if it
didn't trying something else so in the
big landscape of tools this always sort
of makes me chuckle it's just so big
this is where I think the meetups have
been hugely helpful and that you sort of
know what state of the art right now in
the data science community and among our
users as I mentioned we all work in our
and so that's sort of what we want to be
doing so we sort of found some things
that were familiar to us that our group
is using luckily we have some fantastic
computer scientists within labs who were
incredibly helpful but you see here so
we already were using Hadoop for other
things h2o and spark you know we're all
viable options here so we ended up doing
we work within an HDFS environment so
I'll just briefly explain sort of our
setup and as I mentioned of course
anything you can do is conditional on
this but so to start we have a Hadoop
framework that's where a data stored it
also you know we have access to
MapReduce and those sorts of things
yarn is the job scheduler and handles
how resources are allocated so that's a
shared framework across all the
researchers at Labs meaning that no one
person can take over the entire cluster
which was a little bit of a bummer for
us because we wanted the whole cluster
but yeah if you don't you can so then on
top of that I won't go too into detail
on all these but here are some of the
the tools that we considered so Hadoop
MapReduce you know I think some people
think it's becoming obsolete but
ultimately it still does stuff really
pretty well so it's a batch processing
tool it doesn't read anything in memory
so there is a time component to the
reading and the writing to disk and if
you're gonna be building a model it
needs to be paralyzed aband used to be
able to run in a distributed way spark
and h2o let me briefly say hive is sort
of like a sequel background to Hadoop so
it sits on top of it and you can do
interactive queries at scale that was
really helpful for some initial EBA when
we didn't know what we were working with
spark and h2o we also considered again
distributed frameworks here they handle
data a little bit differently so that
spark in particular reads data into
memory which is great and we were able
to do that but then you also need the
memory for computational overhead and
that's where we kind of ran into the
problem of we could only have so much
the cluster so of course we're here to
talk about our and luckily all of these
have interfaces in are so you can use
are on the front end and interact with
these things on the back end we ended up
using Simon Urbanek he's a colleague of
ours and he wrote HMR
which is to do MapReduce for are
essentially and that was really helpful
for a lot of our data processing and
wide casting sparkley are and are
sparkling in h2o are also really great
options for doing this for building
models through our on bigger data so the
next challenge we are now moving into
aid of the US and so I'm excited to hear
some talks later today and tomorrow
about moving a pipeline into production
because that's where we're headed
and in the meantime just huge thanks to
Rick who is as I mentioned been my
colleague and all this as well as our
other collaborators thank you
[Applause]